enough
thank you
[Music]
right now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good morning
can I please ask everyone to take a seat
good morning
foreign
take a seat and make sure your
interpretation is working
merci beaucoupons
[Music]
we will start very shortly
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
the hospital
right now we
are
starting
I think we must have a salon before you
know
they will they will launch
foreign
[Music]
so most of you have taken a seat already
and I would ask everyone now to please
take a seat
watch
okay please take a seat everyone
and we will start shortly yes
so we're waiting a few more seconds and
then we'll start
problems
[Music]
okay
[Music]
she's coming
yeah
as soon as president
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good night
two one
bonjour
hey
[Music]
good morning and welcome to this far
follow-up event to the conference on the
future of Europe welcome to everybody
whether you're attending here in person
or remotely
welcome to the European Parliament in
Brussels
all have your headsets on and
orients This brilliant day together
especially designed for those citizens
who took part in the conference on the
future of Europe to learn how the
institutions have followed up on the
recommendations you made and how they're
moving to put them into practice
I am part of the team that was chosen to
moderate the European citizens panels
and with my colleague we will be
moderating today's today's proceedings
thank you very much and welcome to the
feedback event of the conference on the
future of Europe about 535 citizens made
it today to Brussels despite the strike
in Belgium despite the cold and also
despite the fact that for many of the
citizens for many of you the conference
already finished a year ago
panel 2 of the conference on the future
of Europe finished on the 12th of
December 2021 in Florence and had 39
recommendations and I would like to ask
all members all participants who took
part in panel one all the citizens
please stand up
everyone who was part of panel one
please stand up
and now I realize I mixed it up actually
panel two ended on the 12th of December
in Florence with 39 recommendations but
panel one which we just saw ended on the
27th of February in Dublin with 48
recommendations so could I now ask the
members of panel 2 also to stand up
please
foreign
[Applause]
with 51 recommendations and I would also
like to ask everyone who was part of
panel 3 to stand up please
and last not least panel 4 which
finished on the 13th of February this
year in Maastricht and they finished
with 40 recommendations and so also all
the citizens of panel 4 please stand up
[Applause]
for most of you the last time you saw
each other was at the start of last year
and what we're going to tell you is how
work continued in the meantime your
recommendations the panel's
recommendations were
highlighted by your ambassadors at the
plenary conference of the Europe of the
conference of Europe and those
ambassadors worked with the other
members of the plenary conference
to discuss the recommendations and turn
them into proposals
who attended the plenary conference on
the one hand members of the European and
National parliaments representatives
from the Council of Europe National
authorities Regional authorities local
authorities representatives from the
European commission from civil society
and social partners
a lot of the members of the plenary
conference are here today and we would
like to warmly welcome them yes Applause
quite right
[Applause]
and I will ask you ambassadors please
last time I'm asking you to get some
exercise could you please stand so that
we can thank you for your work
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
and now I would call on all of the
citizens of the panels to get in touch
with their ambassadors to get more
information on what happened even if we
give you the outline you can always get
more details from them and that's always
a good thing thank you all members and
participants of the plenaries worked on
the recommendations and transformed them
into the conference proposals and the
final result is 49 proposals with 326
measures which are part of those
proposals and on my May the name ninth
those proposals were officially handed
over to the three institutions to the
European Parliament the Council of the
European Union and the European
commission and many of you were there on
that day in frasbour
today we are happy to be again in the
European Parliament but this time in
Brussels
and we will today ask and hear about
what happened to those proposals so we
will have representatives from the three
EU institutions to take stock of the
follow-up of the conference on the
future of Europe and to answer your
questions
now I am very honored to announce and
welcome our host of this event today the
president of the European Parliament
Miss Roberta metzola please welcome her
together with me
foreign
yes
good morning thank you dear Judith and
Jacob
nice to see you here vice president Ki
Minister Dr Rosen Elizabeth Normand
welcome to the European Parliament
on Europe day of 2021
at the inaugural event of the conference
on the future of Europe my friend and my
predecessor David sasoli spoke about the
importance of a proper
and meaningful follow-up to the results
of this historic exercise by the three
institutions each at their own levels of
competence he said and I quote
the vision of our European project will
be the compass that must guide our work
in the decade to come
dear Europeans I am proud to stand
before you all as president of the
European Parliament to assure you that
this institution is holding itself to
its word
we were the first institution to react
to your proposals in May of this year
and later also in June
our constitutional Affairs committee is
busy working on another report which
could be voted upon in the next weeks
and today we are gathered here in the
house of European democracy your house
to take stock of what we had done
let me start with my personal feedback
I was elected in January of this year
since then I have met with hundreds even
thousands of people in my role as
president I have met with prime
ministers presidents politicians and
citizens of all ages from all 27 member
states many of these meetings have one
thing in common they all want to talk to
me about the future of Europe
they ask me about the conference about
the proposals that many of you in this
room helped form they asked me about
strengthening the links between citizens
and their elected representatives and
about increasing the transparency of EU
decision making one thing has been
universally clear people want more
European democracy
they also speak to me about legislation
they ask about climate change and the
environment
about the circular economy about the ban
on single-use Plastics about high-speed
and night trains and reducing our
dependency on imported oil and gas
they talk about the impact of the
pandemic on their lives and ask about
the European health union about mental
health and about cross-border exchange
of Health Data
people want to see a stronger economy
social justice and jobs and many of them
ask how the digital transition the
working time directive the youth
guarantee and how tax policies that
support European industry can help
achieve this
they also speak to me about migration
about revising our common Asylum system
so that we can be fair and Humane with
those seeking protection that we can be
firm with those who are not eligible and
strong with traffickers who exploit some
of the most vulnerable people on our
planet
they asked me about the role of young
people in shaping the future of Europe
about lifelong learning voting at the
age of 16.
sport
the youth check on legislation about
inclusiveness
and gender equality
people are worried about the role of
Europe in the world
framed in the context of a war in
Ukraine where the implications on our
democracy are clear
they ask about our Union security and
defense about cyber security measures
about protecting our values Freedom
democracy and the rule of law about
measures to support a pluralistic free
and independent press
fortunately many of the building blocks
to implement your proposals are already
in place and here let me say that I am
encouraged to see that the 2023
commission work program includes many
legislative proposals relating to what
the conference proposed and history as
history including recent history has
shown this European Parliament as
colleges later stands ready to do its
parts diligently effectively and quickly
in the interest of the 450 million
European constituents that It ultimately
represents
as I said in May and I will say it again
when it comes to implementing our
citizens proposals no suggestions for
change should be off limits whatever
process is required in order for us to
get there should be embraced including a
convention
the commission is also here today
[Music]
the commission is also here today and I
know that the commitment given is shared
by our institutions
our goal must be to improve and reform
systems
nothing should be off the table
including treaty change because Vision
takes courage
dear friends when I look at you all here
today seated in the very same places
that your elected representatives vote
upon legislation
I am reminded of how important the
participatory element of the conference
on the future of Europe was
citizens talking to decision makers was
undoubtedly an outstanding part of this
exercise
but it should not be something
exceptional this is where the European
Parliament made up of 705 directly
elected members needs to do more let me
give you an example of a young girl who
I met recently
as we started speaking I quickly noticed
that she had so many positive ideas
about how the European Union can help
make things a little bit easier for the
people who live in her area I suggested
that she writes to her member of the
European Parliament
and she replied you can do that and
sometimes it seems like the only contact
that people have with their elected
representatives is through a like or a
comment on a social media post
of course we cannot force citizens to
talk to their elected representatives
but I believe we can do more to raise
awareness that yes citizens can write to
their members of European Parliament yes
citizens can suggest new ideas to them
yes citizens can recommend new proposals
and in fact they should because that's
our responsibility that is where we need
to show in 2024 that what you told us in
2019 we listened to and we worked on and
we delivered the European Parliament is
not here just in these buildings it is
in every town and Village in our Union
the conference on the future of Europe
and the 49 proposers that you presented
to us on the 9th of May are not the end
this was not a one-off exercise for the
European Union your proposals are not
some checklist that we need to take
to close the door on the conference on
the future of Europe once and for all
because this exercise was ultimately
about readying our Union for the future
whether that be tomorrow the future next
week next year or in 10 years time there
is no end date to the Future and there
is no end date to our Union growing and
continuing to evolve what works for eu27
will not work for eu33 or eu36 we have
Ukraine Moldova the Western Balkans and
George are getting ready but are we
ready
the future is a work in progress
so is our Union and as Robert Schumann
said Europe will not be made all at once
and today I will add that it can never
be complete
grows and develops with each hurdle we
pass through with each breakthrough we
achieve with every little piece of
legislation that manages to make our
shared space a little bit safer a little
bit fairer and a little bit more equal
as president of the European Parliament
I can commit to you that we will keep
working until we can say that this
project is even better than it is today
thank you very much
[Music]
president
thank you very much
for reminding us of the ambition of this
conference on the future of Europe and
also the commitments made by the
institutions
today is a wrap-up day but it's also a
staging post along the way
um as we look at the day-to-day problems
facing all of the inhabitants of Europe
in a moment we'll hear from the three
institutions and we'll have an
opportunity to go much more into depth
in looking into how each of the
institutions is taking up the proposals
made by the conference on the future of
Europe but before that
we'll give the floor to three of you
who've been involved in this adventure
and who will be sharing their
experiences of this conference and as
well as their expectations so without
further Ado I suggest we hear from
uh Rosalind Elizabeth and Norman
Rosalind first please
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning everyone my name is
Rosalina mataman my sons and I'm from
Luxembourg
before I start I'd like to start by
thanking the three institutions for
organizing this event
this was a very enriching experience
from all perspectives uh in terms of
human contact socially politically
cultural and
in many more ways as well
by taking part in the panel
I help it helped me better understand
exactly what the European Union is what
it represents to understand its
institutions and how they work its
Representatives
and above all how important its very
existence is
before I took part in the panel
seemed very elitist and
inaccessible to a normal citizen like me
now I feel much more involved
and I want to get even more involved
going forward
I'm even now managing to tell people
around me about the topic
I believe this conference has allowed
citizens to realize their role and the
place that they occupy within the
European Union
has shown that their voices count
and at the end of the day we are the
future of Europe
[Applause]
thank you Rosalind for
for uh kicking off and we'll hear now
from Elizabeth
come and join us at the podium
[Applause]
good morning everyone
my name is Elizabeth piacentini I'm a
French European citizen I have passed um
actively participated in the panels and
I'm very happy to bring forward the
questions and inquiries and demands from
the citizens who participated in this
citizens panel we're very happy to see
the 49 proposals actually result in
something concrete on the ground and we
want to see this happen as quickly as
possible you owe this to All European
citizens who came forward with their
aspirations and their conviction
we very much want to see
institutions learning lessons and
responding to Citizens expectations in
their daily lives to do this
the best would be to identify and
prioritize measures that need to be done
in the short term and those that can be
handled over the longer term and to
explain why
the goal however has to be to implement
the program as a whole
we need to organize our work
uh we need to build the whole building
but this
foundations have to be solid in this
Spirit citizens have to be brought
closer to the European Union its
institutions its values and
the first uh the starting point is to
find uh confidence and Trust once again
we're seeing an increase in crises um
environmental energy crisis war in
Ukraine and so it's important to
uh bring citizens together in supporting
the European project and to Anchor them
in their fundamental values
the European Union and its institutions
have to be up to the challenge and to
provide a definitive response to the
aspirations of its citizens European
citizens want to see clear Resolute
action on this and we have to
um commit to achieving results on the
ground thank you very much in advance
for responding to our questions and our
concerns and if you do this this will
allow us to live together and happily in
our beautiful home that is Europe
thank you very much Elizabeth and
finally uh to the opening session we'll
hear from uh Normand go ahead please
[Music]
good morning everybody my name is and I
am from Latvia
I took part in the conference and I was
The Ambassador in the group
values and justice
and from today's event I expect complete
transparency and very exact information
a lot has already been achieved and what
is left to be achieved if there are
certain difficulties in the working
process these can be overcome if some of
the recommendations cannot be
implemented we have to know which ones
and why and we really would like the
institutions to tell us
how they envisage that fight in the
future against various types of
discrimination in the member states and
between the member States during the
conference
we we encounter discriminations
regarding language availability and I am
very thankful for that difficulty to
have been solved
regardless of the fact that we come from
different member states we have
different languages we are united we are
united in our attempts to solve these
difficulties and I do hope
that we will arrive at a common
democracy that we will be United in it
and we will be looking towards new a new
structure of the future Europe thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Norman and thank you to all
three of you
I think these first accounts nicely set
the tone and show US citizens
expectations from this step before we
move on to the question and answer
session because citizens have prepared
questions for the institutions I would
suggest we open a conversation with the
three institutions who have also
participated in this um
first time experience at European level
so the commission the European Council
and the European Parliament
that I'll give the floor to Jacob thank
you what you did
yeah as Richard said and as we all know
the conference has been organized by the
three institutions as core signatories
of the joint declaration for the
conference on the future of Europe and
for now I would like to welcome all
members of the European Parliament and
especially and very warmly Mr gifa
hofstad as a co-chair of the conference
on the future of Europe
Mr fell said the floor is yours
thank you
[Music]
so uh first of all uh thank you very
much to the the 535
citizens uh who are here today we are
only missing how many 200s I think 250
or something like that but I think it's
a very good attendance rate it's even
sometimes better than the parliament
itself the attendance rate uh and uh so
I'm very pleased that that you're all
here and it's it's also a little bit an
emotional moment everybody
sees friends back that we didn't see for
for seven months now
um
emotional Gathering because also that
remembers me what the most emotional
citizens panel that I have participated
in that was in in you remember that in
Dublin
not because of the Guinness beer that
was also part of the of of that panel
awful beer in my opinion but okay so but
not too many Irish people here hopefully
but
um emotional why because you remember
that it were the citizens who as the
first in that panel reacted to the start
of the war in Ukraine and said look
this conference cannot go on if we don't
take into account what is happening
today in Ukraine why because these
people in Ukraine the citizen Ukraine
who are not there in all citizens panels
but who are in our might and in our
heart they are fighting for European
values they are fighting for the
European ideals better than we do it the
last decades in Europe
and um
I found it a very emotional moment
because it was citizens who oppressed us
uh to to put Ukraine in the middle of
our discussions
and in the meanwhile uh I think many of
our or citizens I I even have heard that
some of our citizens have entered in
politics so even that happened the last
seven months
but we concluded dear friends at these
conclusions of the conference seven
months ago and if you look backwards I
think we can say today that off today
more reasons to implement the
conclusions of the conference than seven
months ago and why I am saying that
because in the meanwhile
since the end of our conference what we
have seen is uh
the need for social support
in European Union due to the crisis
the need for an energy transition for an
energy Union
we have seen more need for defense
cooperation inside the European Union we
have seen that there is a need that
finally we have a migration strategy
in Europe and we have seen the need for
more foreign policy diplomacy to end in
fact what is happening on the ground in
the neighborhood of of Europe so so I
would say that if you look today to the
world there is more reason to implement
the conclusions of the conference than
seven months ago
and I have to tell you that I I want to
thank the the European Commission
because the European commission has done
a lot of work
in the last seven months what they have
done is they have put a maximum of
proposals of your proposals inside the
commission work program
that has been presented uh a few months
ago by commissioner the head of the
commission Mrs vonderlane to the
Parliament and and to the public
but besides that we have to be honest in
my opinion it's not enough
it's very good what the commission has
done and that's the task of the
commission to do that but we as three
institutions have a common
responsibility a common responsibility
not only to
realize 60 or 65 percent or seventy
percent of this proposal had never such
a rate that at school that's not the the
issue or the problem but it's not enough
to say okay we have done 60 70 percent
of the proposals have been realized in
the working program of the commission
what needs to be done is the 100 percent
all the proposals of the conference are
so important that they need to be
implemented in reality and in practice
and um
let's be honest that means that uh we
need for that to reform the European
Union a lot of your proposals have an
obstacle a hurdle cannot be realized
because we need to change the
competences of the Union because we need
to change the rules inside the European
Union to make it happen
I can give a few examples a health union
health union is not in the competence of
the unit for the moment
a full energy Union is not in the
competence of the European Union for the
moment because of of the lack of
competencies
we have no let's be honest a real
migration strategy that is agreed
between Council and and Parliament for
uh the the moment so we cannot Implement
your proposals uh on on migration
we have not a common forum and security
policy in a lot of areas because of the
unanimity problem that we have in
European union or whatever we look to it
the most of the proposals that you have
formulated will need also a reform of
the European Union from the inside
better rules less unanimity more
majority decision making and
competencies like Health Energy and
education that needs to be in the heart
of the European Union
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's uh for that simple reason uh dear
citizens that we were the parliament a
few months ago have asked for a
convention
what is a convention a convention is not
changing the treaties right now A
convention is a place
where the institutions will meet each
other to discuss the reform of the Union
that can lead to a treaty change that's
possible
that can also lead to new competences
for the European Union hopefully that
will be the outcome but a convention is
in all idea necessary to put everybody
around the table giving the conclusions
of the conference of the future of
Europe and saying okay to make this
happen what needs to be changed in Union
can we continue for example I will only
give one example to not make it too too
depressive today
and that is unanimity
as we are speaking today there are in
the council for the moment for
important issues blocked
because of unanimity
first of all I give you the list
the fact that we need to give 80 billion
of budgetary Aid to Ukraine but it's
absolutely key these people are fighting
for their country and for our values
they need our financial aid not only
military but also money to survive in
their fight against Russia that's needed
to pay the pensions to pay the salaries
of the military
it's blocked today
we have on the international level
finally an agreement on a minimum tax on
multinationals that's one of your key
proposals in the conference on the
future of Europe saying that everybody
has to pay his fair tax and also break
your tax companies of from America needs
to do it and with that money we can go
forward in the European Union with a
number of Investments also policies and
so on
blocked in the council blocked in the
institutions because of unanimity
there is a recovery plan of every
country
including Hungary that needs to be
approved the pandemic is already two
years ago so that recovery plan needs to
be approved and at the same time we need
to apply the rule of law in all
countries of the European Union also and
certainly in Hungary there it needs to
be applied
these four issues were key issues in
European Union
[Music]
these four issues were key issues in
European Union are linked to each other
I should say typical bugs and policy but
uh as I am a Belgian I will not make the
reference to that
so your proposals were good proposals
that we share that we have approved in a
conference need to go over that obstacle
and therefore we have said let's start
to look to reform abolish unanimity the
fastest as possible so that finally the
wish of the people can be implemented
the fastest as possible
so
I go never over my time in the
parliament so I will do it not now
either
but in any way
I have two requests
that is first of all that you keep the
pressure
keep depression not only here in the
parliament but keep the pressure also to
your National parliaments and National
governments to make this happen
and my second is that we as institutions
take a responsibility working together
making this happen so that when we see
each other next year
because I would invite all the citizens
again next year and that way maybe we
can tell them at that moment
[Music]
but we can show them that we have made
real progress in 2023 thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you to Mr hofstadt for having
um
underlined the conclusions and how the
confidence in the future of Europe can
be a driver for change in Europe and
also the discussions that this provokes
within the institutions I think this is
very important for the citizens to hear
thank you for that I would now like to
invite the next speaker to explore how
the institutions have taken up our
proposals
Minister Beck for the Council of Europe
Mr Beck is the Czech Minister for
European Affairs and you're currently
presiding over the council Czech
Republic currently has the rotating
president of the European Union go ahead
please
[Music]
thank you dear citizens dear friends
I'm obviously going to be the most Dow
speaker of today because
my job is not to speak for myself or for
the Czech government but my duty is to
represent the common denominator of 27
member states in the council 27 member
states with different historical
backgrounds political cultures
problems in the social or economic area
so I will have to keep low profiles
myself
and I have to speak for the consensus
among the member states
it's now time for the institutions to
report back and give you feedback on the
work take out since the 9th of May
today I am therefore particularly happy
to meet you all and to represent to you
the work undertaken by the council for
the implementation of your proposals
I can proudly say that the council has
been working in Earnest along with the
other institutions towards the
implementation of the outcomes of the
conference
as you may know the council is the
institution composed of members of the
governments of the 27 member states of
the European Union who meet in 10
different configurations
depending on the issues being discussed
one of the council's main tasks is to
adopt EU legislation most of the time as
Eco legislator with the European
Parliament based on a proposal from the
European commission and in some cases as
the main decision maker
the general affairs Council which
gathers the ministers for European
Affairs of your countries and which I
have presided since July has examined
the topic of the conference follow-up at
each of its meetings since May on a
monthly basis
the council's work to implement the
results of the conference started right
after the closing of the conference
indeed the council under the Czech
presidency first informally met to
discuss this issue just two weeks after
the beginning of the presidency since
then we have worked comprehensively and
continuously to identify common ground
and positions through a variety of means
whether questionnaires on specific
issues or debates of the Council on
Grand political decisions
we have notably work on the basis of a
very comprehensive and detailed analysis
of each of your 49 proposals and 326
specific measures measures
this analysis helped us to understand
what was already being done in the
fields covered by your proposals and
most importantly what remained to be
done and how it could be done
the document is public and fully
accessible on the council's website as
well as the conference multilingual
digital platform
two main things came out from this
analysis
the first is that the significant number
of your proposals actually resonate with
existing ongoing or very soon upcoming
initiatives from the EU institutions
the
2019-2024 Strategic agenda of the
European Council which provides an
overall framework and direction for the
work of the Union is in this perspective
very much aligned with the with the
outcome of the conference
the second and probably most important
one is that your proposals in the
overwhelming majority of cases can be
implemented within the established
treaty framework meaning through all the
legal and policy making tools that are
already at our disposal
this led the council to decide to
address as a matter of priority this
very majority of proposals with a clear
objective to provide answers to your
main concerns in the most effective
possible way and to deliver concrete
policies that have a real positive
impact on your daily lives let me
outline a few examples
under the topic of strong economy social
justice and jobs your proposals notably
ask for sustainable growth stronger
social policies and inclusive labor
markets
no later than this October the council
adopted in total alignment with your
requests groundbreaking legislation on
adequate minimum wages in the EU as well
as gender balance on company boards
together with the parliament
similarly your call to take decisive
steps in the fight against global
warming under the theme of climate
change and the environment has fed into
very important Council actions since May
such as the definition of a very
ambitious EU mandate for the cop 27
climate Summit in November or agreement
with the parliament on stronger
carbon dioxide emission standards for
cars and vans
on health where you advocated for
strengthening the resilience and
effectiveness of Health Systems the
council recently adopted two regulations
to improve the eu's capacity to respond
to Future pandemics and cross-border
Health crisis
finally the council has dedicated much
effort to address some of your proposals
that are particularly relevant in the
extraordinary context of Russian's war
of aggression against Ukraine your
proposals on energy called on the EU to
reduce its dependency on foreign actors
member states progressed a lot on the
facing out of the eu's dependence on
Russian fossil fuels
adopted a regulation on coordination
demand reduction measures for guests in
August and a regulation to address High
Energy prices in October
further regulations on enhancing
solidarity through better coordination
of guest purchases exchanges of gas
across borders and reliable price
benchmarks on speeding up permitting
procedures for Renewables and on Market
correction mechanism are to be discussed
at the next extraordinary energy Council
in mid-December
your proposals under EU in the world
called on the EU to assert its ability
to issue sanctions against foreign
entities and individuals that go against
its fundamental principles the council
work day and night to adopt eight
packages of sanctions against Russia at
a scale never seen before
these are a few examples of significant
and very concrete achievements and there
has been more the council's document
analyzing your proposals has been
updated this week to outline the actions
undertaken by the EU since the 9th of
May for the implementation of your
proposals I invite you to consult this
document online to have more details
about what has been done I will also
certainly have the opportunity to expand
on some of them later today during our
Exchange
so much has been done and more will be
done work on going as part of the
established policy making procedures
as you may know EU policy making is a
complex process and as I said the
council usually needs an initiative from
the European commission to take action
this is why at this stage an important
part of the work to follow up on your
proposals goes to the commission first
which is the institution that has the
competence to prepare initiatives for EU
action
in this context the council has been
following with great attention the
commission's follow-up to the conference
and has notably welcomed its clear
commitment to put forward conference
related initiatives which materializes
in its work program for 2023. the
council discussed the program for the
upcoming period and it will together
with the Parliament and the commission
sign in mid-December a joint Declaration
on legislative priorities
the council looks forward to receiving
the commission proposals that will
follow up on the conference outcome and
is ready to play its full institutional
role as part of the legislative process
in addition although much goes to the
commission for now the council has also
proactively in identified and started to
examine the conference proposals for
which it could act on its own
this represents a small but no less
important part of your proposals in
particular several conference proposals
called for enhancing the eu's
decision-making capacity including in
the context of major geopolitical
challenges
this is why the Czech presidency has
decided for the first time in years to
initiate discussions on the possible use
of so-called personal Clauses which are
Provisions in of the treaty that could
allow the council to switch from
unanimity to qualified majority voting
in certain policy areas such as as
expressed in your proposals foreign and
security policy
as it is often the case this is a
flexibility provided by the current
treaty framework
complex discussion which needs time
assessment and reflection your proposals
reflect the sensitivity of the issue and
are the basis for our work in this
regard
in parallel I would like to stress that
not only the council as a whole but also
all of its 27 member states are
committed to continue the work of on the
conference on the future of Europe at
National level
as you know all member states had
actively contributed to the conference
process notably by organizing National
citizens panels and National events
many member states are still intensely
working to take forward the
recommendations put forward by their
citizens at National level in the
framework of the conference and are also
organizing follow-up events in this
regard
finally let me turn to the conference
specific measures which would require a
revision of the current treaties to be
fully implemented
these represent again a very limited
number of the total
the council has taken note of the
European Parliament resolution tasking
its committee on constitutional Affairs
to prepare proposals for treaty
amendments accordingly and already
submitting to the council to such very
specific proposals
taking into account this ongoing work in
the European Parliament the council
believes it is important that all the
proposals for treaty amendments from the
parliament are ready before the next
steps are taken not least in order to
ensure procedural efficiency
this is especially the case in the
current International context which
calls on the EU institutions to focus
all their efforts on the major urgent
challenges posed by the Russian
aggression against Ukraine which a long
and complex process like treat revision
would not solve against this backdrop
the council considers that priority must
be given at this stage to the 95 percent
of conference proposals which can be
implemented without any treaty change
and which will contribute to provide
through concrete European policy direct
answers to the immediate challenges
faced by Europeans
on the parliament complete completes
once the parliament completes its work
the council will be ready in line with
its obligations under article 48 of the
treaty as well as its commitment to
ensure the best follow-up to the
conference to submit the proposals it
will have received to the European
Council and to notify the national
parliaments
dear citizens this is in a nutshell what
the council has been undertaking since
the 9th May to give the most concrete
and effective possible follow-up to your
proposals
now you may wonder what's next as you
can see work is well underway on the
implementation of your proposals many
have matched with existing ongoing or
soon upcoming elections on the other
hand many others do require fed action
from the evens institutions you can
witness from this event that they are
very well received and will be subject
to a thorough follow-up
I therefore invite you in the following
month to take a close look at the action
of EU institutions including to death of
the council look at what we do dig into
the acts we adopt you will see that a
lot actual links to your proposals and
in that way contributes to create as a
follow-up to the unprecedented exercise
that the conference has been the future
of Europe you have designed thank you
very much
thank you thank you very much Minister
Beck
um and last not least I would like to
welcome all members of the European
commission and most especially I would
like to welcome the co-chair of the
conference on the future of Europe and
vice president for democracy and
democracy democracy which is Mr grafka
suicide which we all know and Mrs Sutra
vice president of the floor is yours
thank you
thank you good morning to everybody dear
ladies and gentlemen they are citizens
of all generations across all member
states I want to give you a warm welcome
to European Parliament to Brussels and
it's a great pleasure for me to take
part in this big event this morning and
to see so many familiar faces again
since I speak on behalf of European
commission it's not an easy task to talk
after Minister Beck but also after Mr
hofstadt who gave the tone so I try my
best
as you know we have been working with
the proposals of the conference on the
future of Europe ever since 9th of May
before we move on to the more detailed
feedback on your proposals I want to
take a few steps back let us look once
again at our Point of Departure to look
at just how far we have truly come and
together this can be an unprecedented
Journey as all of you know this also has
been a human Journey this has been a
journey that has challenged all our
lives in many ways this has been a
journey that will now have a direct
impact on millions of citizens across
the European Union as we follow up on
your proposals
going back a step takes me to a time
before Kobe 19. from the beginning of my
mandate as the commission vice president
responsible for the conference I was
fascinated by the idea of launching a
debate on the future of Europe with
randomly selected citizens at the very
center there were many spec there were
many Skeptics at the beginning many who
thought that this could not work or who
thought that this would be a threat to
representative democracy some wanted to
assure that to ensure that the citizens
only had a limited role in the
deliberations including them out of the
plenary
keeping them out of the planet keeping
you out of the planetary and don't
forget that we did all this in 24
languages and we had to organize this in
a pandemic and then we also get got the
war on our doorstep and it is a
remarkable development the process
itself proved the Skeptics wrong and
many of those captives came to see the
value of these deliberative process
we saw in real terms that it adds value
when citizens are given the opportunity
to deliberate about the key issues they
have to face in their daily lives
and you came forward with the 49
reasonable and tangible proposals and
the Skeptics and millions of others took
note of the concrete proposals submitted
to the three institutions as I have said
from the very beginning citizens won the
institutions to listen to them and then
they expect institutions to act and once
we have started to act they expect the
feedback they need I also said before
all this started that providing feedback
would be our Benchmark for our success I
insisted on devising a feedback
mechanism and so here we are today
at the key part in the journey we have
been on together
to say that we have some very
very good citizens who participated in
the thousands of events held across our
Union who contributed online also online
on the multilingual digital platform
my colleagues have spoken about how
their institutions have reacted to the
conference in the months since the since
the 9th of May this year
so I will give you an account of the
European commission's follow-up the
first step was the publication of a
communication commission's communication
on the 17th of June less than six weeks
after the conference closing event in
this document we offered an assessment
of the conference proposals and the
roadmap on how the commission would
follow up and the action and how the
commission will will take action on it
to be credible the commission found it
essential to stick to the spirit and the
letter of what is proposed without any
re-interpretation or selection in fact
we had already started the job
immediately
just two days after the closing event on
the 11th of May we adopted the European
strategy for a better internet for kids
this included measures that were
directly inspired by the deliberations
of the conference
we also recently adopted the U.S action
plan in the European external action
crucially the plan proposes to apply the
one-third youth participation rule from
the conference to relevant exercises
that we will hold with our partners
outside the European Union and we listen
to the calls for greater citizens
engagement in two crucial ways first of
all we will strengthen our online
engagement into in by creating a single
entry point to all citizens engagement
tools that the commission currently has
and will have at this proposal the
upgraded heavier say portal will
accommodate all our public consultations
the European citizens initiatives and
citizens panels it will also include the
child participation platform which has
learned which we launched in September
and this will provide our youngest
citizens with the opportunity to offer
their views on the issue that most
matter to them
but perhaps most relevant of all the
communication adopted in June embeds the
liberative Democracy into our policy
making process from now on citizens
panels will be an integral part of how
we devise policy this is a key success
of the conference and the sign of
innovation in democracy at European
level citizens will make recommendations
before we present any key legislation
legislative initiative I believe that it
is the first time that that an executive
body anywhere in the world is embedding
such an approach
in its policy making process and this is
our major development
[Applause]
of these citizens panels will address
the issue of food waste we are currently
recruiting citizens
through random selection and their work
will start in exactly two weeks from
today on the 16th of December maybe
someone of you will be selected a second
citizen panel on learning Mobility will
be followed in January February but and
then by a third on Virtual Worlds and
the metaverse and we do not stop here
because your proposals continue to
inspire our work the European commission
has adopted to this new past conference
environment we have literally changed
the way in which we work
president found the line in her State of
the Union Address in September announced
herself the First new commission
initiative stemming from the conference
[Music]
five out of 43 initiatives in the
commission work program for next year
are direct response or indirect response
to the conference proposals more than 80
percent conference proposals were a key
driver of the next year's planning yes I
know he said hundred percent should be
done but we need some uh some actions
before that this is also a very a unique
Innovation you have literally told us
what our work next year should be so and
I will stop here because my colleague
vice president Maro Chef which will give
will give you some further details on
this later he was in charge of
commission work program
I should however note that while the
commission has the right to propose and
initiate EU legislation his proposals
will only become law when there is
agreement by the council and by European
Parliament so we propose and we have to
align with European Council and in
European Parliament this is why we are
standing here before you today together
and this is why we are collectively
delivering on the outcomes of the
conference I'm quite confident in saying
here today that democracy will never be
the same again we have changed it you
have changed it you the citizens have
made that happen hand-in-hand with
policy makers
and to conclude our follow-up is not
limited to delivering new laws or taking
other policy actions the lessons learned
from the conference contribute to
updating our Democratic institutions
making our democracy fit for the future
it is not dramatic to say that globally
we Face a pivotal moment for democracy
war is Raging in our neighborhood a way
of autocracy sees one-third of the
various population living in countries
where freedom and openness are being
curtailed we observe the erosion of
democratic norms and Trust in our
Democratic institutions
and we see this occurring at all levels
local and Regional National and European
I'm personally sensitive to this having
been elected at different levels of
governance myself however it's not all
bad news and this is due to one
important reason I am grateful for this
fact that citizens U citizens are
willing to be more engaged in your
democracy Beyond The Ballot Box in the
fight for our Democratic Values our best
allies are our citizens you are our best
allies you have left us Legacy and we
proudly take that Legacy
forward to make better policies for all
our citizens for All Our Generations
leaving no one behind and nowhere behind
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much Madam vice president
for thank you for having
stressed
the sustainable changes introduced by
coffee in terms of the links between
citizens and the European institutions
and underpinning European democracy
thank you to all of the representatives
of the European institutions
and thank you for having started to tell
us this morning about the Practical
steps taken to introduce the changes
that have been recommended by citizens
and for explaining how this can change
all of Europe and change citizens lives
we'll continue this Collective
exploration of those points but before
it's unprecedented for so many of us to
be here and so as an exercise in
transparent democracy we would suggest
taking a family photo so if I can ask
everybody to remain where they are but
to rise to their feet
and we will have a wonderful photo to
remind us of this day which is just a
stage in the journey but it's an
important stage
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]